I'm blessed to be associated with dodge
the most iconic car in history
the audience has its own relationship to
dodge I think that's a testament to with
the car has been incorporated in
profitable from the stories perspective
throughout the saga in this installment
we reveal some really cool dodge cars
this time around we got the tantrum
charger I mean it's over the top and
then some really just an extension of
his character primarily the car is made
out of carbon fiber this unbelievable
workmanship and it has 2,000 horsepower
as a Mercruiser motor and a twin
turbocharged then it's private of 71 GT
exits really the next body style of the
GTX city had at seven Tamiya said Dom
all over because you can put a gigantic
rear tire has huge brew wheel wells in
it so we're able to put a tire that was
I think 16 inches wide on a 20 inch
wheel and that is really a key element
because of what he's doing in this
sequence he's dragging these cars it had
to be a lot of rubber on the ground to
sell that
[Music]
the biggest problem about shooting in
New York City is people they walk
everywhere they go you have a lot more
people on the ground in New York City
than you have in any other city and the
fact that they're not going to stop for
a movie crew you have to really be
thinking all the time just to keep
everything safe because the streets are
crowded when you do get them off the
street they're off the street by about a
quarter-inch they don't step off back
away from the curb and you can become by
forty five fifty miles an hour right
against the curb and they are not moving
we had 150 to 200 people around of the
cars we weren't using and I was just
amazed that you'd see from every single
lifestyle from every single part of the
world people taking pictures of fast and
furious cars and police officers are
coming over and leaning down in saying
hey can I you know come over and lead
down to get a picture the New York
Police Department came in I got to say
that they are a big fan of fast and
furious too they let us do things a
little more than what I think they
normally do and said we're going to let
you do it until we can see that you're
at a point where we think it's dangerous
I'm never going to say no because nobody
has ever done what we've done in New
York City and the New York Police
Department in the mayor were part of
[Music]
when Letty and dahmer in Cuba Dom finds
himself racing in a vehicle that turns
out to be a ticking time bomb now we're
taking you to the behind-the-scenes of
this blazing race down the scenic mullah
Kong in Havana to see how we pulled it
off
why are you hooking up my cousin Cochran
cousin's car not anymore
we had morning I gave it to him he can't
fake I take the car one thing that I did
when I started on and fate of the fury
is worse to do my homework to the
research I wanted to figure out what the
fans loved about this franchise and what
they missed it there's anything they
miss it what I keep hearing is just
going back to the basics car racing car
race is just racing for pink light you
want to call it the right word
baseball our characters have evolved to
kind of save the world status that it's
hard to justify a race anymore in this
universe so we were adamant about trying
to find the perfect place to set that up
and the Hydra that we were able to make
this race about honor was such a cool
thing and such a throwback to the first
one ionically having this dodge demon is
just such an asset to the film I got to
give credit to the universal team and
the Dodge security team that they've
been able to keep this under wraps
I mean that's just incredible
very limited edition of these cars I
think fastest street car ever made this
is a car that's going to produce over
800 horsepower it's basically ready for
the drag strip you get it from the
dealer and you could literally drive the
drag strip you open the trunk there's
two skinny lightweight you know front
drag tires card comes with sticky drag
radials in the back feel the car we keep
a little sub ten-second times in the
quarter mile it's going to be that fast
quite if it goes into converting them
over to the demon brake upgrades
suspension upgrades wheels tires body
modifications interior - hardly release
right of the release of the film what a
perfect joint venture I think gods
really stepped up on fasting they had
been wonderful and they have been very
supportive but the bar was set high the
great thing is going into the people
that all believe they can achieve that
next level one of the best things about
making Fast and Furious movies is
getting to take our fans around the
world with us we love exploring new
places and in the fate of the Furious we
had the unbelievable opportunity to
travel to Cuba and bring the taste of
the Cuban culture to our audience here's
a look at our experience shooting in
Cuba from its beautiful cities to the
inviting people who welcomed us with
open arms
[Applause]
[Music]
this is one of the most impossible
location to lock down and shoot for a
number of reasons and we happen to be
the very first studio movie to shoot in
Havana and Cuba period that's a major
see right now I am going to meet members
of the US embassies here Cuba which is
very helpful and allowing us to this
module this is the team that helped us
do the impossible I want to say thank
you from the bottom of my heart go group
our group in order for us to shoot in
Cuba we brought everything from the
toilet paper to the cameras we brought
everything there every toilet director
could ever want
it is not only here but if we Cuba which
means that we had projects up on the
ship on a plane on a submarine whatever
we did we got it out here and we're
bringing the infrastructure to Cuba
there's not much here especially to
shoot a movie of this side two one
[Music]
momentum m-maggie bomyeo cydia on
tracing kochava so nikita Molonglo
receipt rentable sona yahu nasi men
Solomon d'oeuvre um can go oon available
on caliber ammo lo ciento cincuenta
attentive resume access primera hey
Ellis areas inner wall you see these
camera cars you see edge arms you see
our motorbikes and stuff like that you
can cover even through the video village
this stuff has never been seen before
here we coupled with a crew from Cuba
and so now I had to essentially lead the
American crew and the Cuban crew and
bring them together and so you never
know what you're going to get when you
do something like that because it's
almost like a creative social experiment
but we all came together the cuban crew
and the American crew and family being a
theme for the story became the theme for
our crew mr. nobody is no one and
nothing a high power low profile enigma
who has the uncanny ability to get
others to act and now he's got a protege
go behind the scenes to get to know the
unknowable nobodies hey my new home base
welcome to nowhere we always loved to
bring in new characters and the faster
Furious franchise Kurosawa was a seven
he came in as sort of this mysterious
character who are you I'm mr. nobody
nobody being a guy who we don't exactly
know much about he knows anything he
wants to know about everybody he's the
kind of guy that's involved in things we
cannot imagine now I'm going to show you
how to get this done we don't know
anything about him don't even know his
name mister nobody's nobody he is
apparently involved with the government
moment where he Phyllis and I think
that's probably the way to look at it
he's apparently involved with them it
doesn't mean he's with them
and it doesn't mean he's on his own find
out as a connection here to Hobbs it's
good to see you don't worry you too
where he gets his money from who he's
really working for it could be a line
that often changed you never can trust
mr. nobody all the way and I think that
is the delicious fun of that character
and curve plays it to the help when you
see the love and care the TLC they put
into these cars it's on a whole nother
level
and especially given that they don't
have the access to the parts that we
have in that one remote those big
particles no way yeah how long it goes
to show how being oppressed for such a
long time cultivated that ingenuity taxi
drivers they drive the old 1950 Chevy's
Cadillacs and I was reading the Namit on
one of them where they have like 650
thousand kilometers on it which is crazy
it's not just kind of like oh car it's
the classics their families have
experienced life through these cars so
they have a different attachment to
these vehicles than say what we do in
the state and come follow bullet et 1956
when he's a plus to my father then my
billet I know to me Cuba is all about
that car culture you got these cars from
1961 and later like if there is a
perfect guy to be immersed in that
culture it's done this is a Cuban spirit
sure is bitter good
you